bonjour vincent à la villa du
département en tant que chef d'equipe
jardinier aujourd'hui je vais vous
présenter comment s'occuper d'un massif
donc le rendre encore plus beau nous
avons un joli massif avec de l'igs aura
du croûton impatience la guinée de la
sole du corps dealing mov et je vais
vous expliquer comment faire le binage
pourquoi le faire le binage c'est simple
il suffit juste de avec une grade de
retourner le sol pour aérer le sol est
apportée à la plante l'eau et les
nutriments nécessaires pour sa atteindre
la plante plus facilement de cassis
racines et par la même occasion lors du
minage on va désherber à la main
important toujours la paire de gants se
protéger c'est très important pour tg
les mains on sait pas ce qu'il ya dans
le sol des fois une petite gratte aussi
est juste avec ça je vais vous montrer
comment on fait le ménage
donc c'est entier on va commencer à vous
choisissiez n'importe quel côté on va
venir
retournez le sol en même temps on va
désherber mais toujours il faut super
faire attention quand même à la plante
donc s'il faut pas hésiter à la toucher
et surtout pas la tène les racines avec
la gratte on va apporter de l'air on va
mélanger latéraux tour donc apporter des
nutriments l'eau s'infiltrer dans le sol
plus facilement
donc au final la plante elle se portera
mieux essayer d'enlever le maximum les
herbes comme celle-ci du trèfle à trois
feuilles d une mauvaise herbe qui est
envahissante
à cause de ces bulbes va essayer au
maximum d' enlever les feuilles et
surtout les bulles passionnant même si
on n'allait pas les bulles ils vont
repousser au final ça aura pas servi à
grand chose
bonjour mais aussi tout ce qui est faux
yaz parce que pour nous le site
il faut que le sol soit comme propres
pour certaines personnes les feuilles
on va dire que c'est sale mais c'est
faux c'est normalement on devrait
laisser sa fait un paillage naturel
lorsqu'on retourne le sol auront fait le
ménage
alors c'est le moment idéal pour voir si
la plante n'a pas de maladie si elle se
porte bien si lui ment pas de l'engrais
comment et le sol s'il est trop sexy les
s'il est trop dur il suffit d'observer
la plante au vent s'il a pas de malade
ici on voit pas sous les feuilles
surtout s'il n'ya pas d'insectes
bon c'est quand même physique tout ça
c'est pas facile c'est pas à la portée
de tout le monde donc il ya une suite de
solutions pour les gens qui veulent pas
désarmer ou qui ne peuvent pas le faire
on va tout simplement rajouté un
paillage que ce soit un plastique un peu
comme dans les cultures salle à dix
mètres un plastique un paillage en
copeaux de bois
ensuite il faut savoir choisir parce que
le paillage 2
de copeaux de défense de pain n'est pas
toujours la bonne solution parce que la
plante et réagit à l'acidité du copo de
pain il ya des plantes comme ça des
plantes qui déteste ça donc faut faire
très attention au paillage qu'on va
utiliser donc bombe après avoir un peu
transpirer on voit que les plantes sont
toujours intactes l'essentiel c'est que
ce sabot pour les yeux pour les gens et
pour nous-mêmes surtout c'est pas mal